[Music]
ladies there gentlemen we're live are we
really so you're the opening voice is
that what it is moving forward
did you just hire yourself walking
around restaurants bumping into women
pissing them off
he caught beef last night
and i apologize
to to the lady that david bumped into on
behalf of our entire crew we apologize
david sometimes does tend to do that but
it is what it is anyways how you feeling
i feel great i'm glad you're doing this
today
we just decided on doing this literally
a few minutes ago 45 minutes ago
and i know we've had it up but it wasn't
agreed upon 15 minutes 15 minutes ago
you're right yeah 15 minutes ago so
people are already saying vividlpbd
thank you five bucks you didn't talk
about pandora papers in china clapping
clamping down on internet's last podcast
uh we will get right into that we have a
few different things that we're going to
cover let me give you some of the
stories that we have that we're
interested in talking about
and we may do one fun topic okay
just one we may do one which would be
what would be guys
what would be your superpower and why we
may talk about that i think some people
would want yours
mine specifically i want to know yours
adam big time yeah
i want to know what love is i want to
know what love is
gerard on cue
by the way you guys were like
when we when we lived in skokie illinois
we were part of a barbershop quartet i
couldn't see that we were doing that i
can totally shout out to chad
so so by the way can you grab adam's the
latest additional playboy he had on his
desktop
if you haven't described it all right
just grab it so we'll talk about that
bitcoin prices apparently is 55 000
today it's really not stopping donald
trump
dropped off forbes list of wealthiest
americans for the first time in 25 years
maybe danielle is right you know daniel
assam said trump's never been a
billionaire before but anyways we'll
cover that uh
believe that he was not a billionaire of
course he's a billionaire biden warns
meteor headed to crash into u.s economy
and debt struggle folks if your english
is not your first language he's not
saying a meteor is headed to or because
i thought that's what he was talking
about at first meaning the economy is
about to take a massive hit
if we don't extend
uh the uh what do you call it the the
three and a half trillion dollars or
tomasaki
won't say whether hunter biden has
divested from chinese private equity
from can you imagine you can't answer a
simple question like that trump says he
knows what would happen if faces
desantis in 2024 presidential primary i
talked about this last week when i said
this will be a problem
literally a day and a half later he
answered so maybe he listened to the
podcast and said i would and i'm going
to read it here in a minute but go ahead
jordan you're going to say something no
no no no no that was like he the gop has
a donald trump problem now gop has a
donald trump property how about we start
with that how about we start with that
how about we start we mean now i don't
think
now the gop has a donald trump problem
as it goes to
what's been going on
yeah what do you mean what's different
now
what do you mean what's different now
you guys are trying to understand you're
not even waiting today you're going to
go out right off the bat i don't know i
i didn't understand what they come out
you mean the gop has a donald trump
problem now yes like something's new
today with donald trump but do you know
what he's saying that's what i'm asking
yeah he's saying like you're gonna have
to go through meaning he's not backing
down right so this is that's obvious and
they have nothing to gain from it yeah
they were never gonna win
they there was nobody that they had that
was a candidate that was going to carry
the election against hillary clinton so
donald trump was a necessary evil for
the gop so i thought we just said what
he said this is a fox news story
trump says he knows what would happen if
he faces desantis in 2024 election
primaries less than a week before he
returns to the state that kicks off the
race for the white house former
president trump it says in a new
interview that if he runs for president
again most of the republi republicans
will drop out but if governor desantis
also makes a bid for 2024 european
nomination trump emphasized i would beat
him he would trump remains the
overwhelming front run on all the
extremely early polls in 2024 but in
hypothetical question with trump not on
the ballot desantis and former vice
president mike pence topped a large
field of potential contenders in the
survey desantis pushback against 2024
speculation last week telling fox news
host john hannity i'm not considering
anything beyond doing my job so trump is
already saying i would be desantis
somebody uh somebody in the gop
somebody needs to get in there and just
figure it out before it gets on camera
yep somebody needs to get in and say i
don't care if it's rock paper scissors i
don't care if it's red light green light
i don't care if it's flip a coin you we
can't have these guys go out there let
me ask you what would ron desantis do to
joe biden in a debate
would it would it be the biggest
massacre in the history of debates would
it would it be uh
the the rhetorical equivalent of an
early mike tyson knockout joe would call
in sick three times
he would joe biden would want none of
ron desantis and joe biden beat trump in
one of the debates so i i think donald
trump that's a lot of bluster i think
donald trump he was a phenomenon there's
nobody that can argue what maggot was
and and you know what it created and how
he mirrored a lot of what the democrats
did to
generate this cult of personality i mean
basically he mirrored the obama campaign
not not the not the policies and
ideology obviously but the cult of
personality and and the i think this is
this is the different questions so c
johnson just gave for the 4.99
appreciate you buddy and this says
john uh ron desantis he said dos santos
ron desantis won't run against trump his
time frame his time will come in 20 28.
so here's a question for you here's a
question for you that makes sense okay
here's odds odds what are the chances
desantis runs
2023 2024 as he runs 50 50.
um
i think trump owns the gop i don't think
i think we're doing
i think we are
knighting ron desantis like he's some
presidential candidate do you need a
calculator just before i'm going to say
what i want to say
percentage buddy i don't think he's
running i think that's okay
it's not zero because like
i would say less than ten percent i
think trump owns the gop and we're
trump desantis has done nothing on the
national stage yet that's not right
that's not true though he's obviously
done a great job in florida
in florida got gerrard to move here did
a great job getting gerard keep your
friends in jersey
um
but he doesn't want democrats in the
state i just don't want him by the way
most people agree with you most people
here are saying he's not running the
only person that's a 75 percent chance
he's running phil what do you think i
don't think he's running okay i don't
think he's running i mean i think but i
do think
trump will poke that bear
nonstop where
in my opinion
desantis you know he could always change
his mind and say you know what like i'm
not going to back down from this i i
will go toe-to-toe with you but uh i do
look at desantis as a you know a
competitive person
that but the difference is that he can
be competitive while showing more
discipline than trump can
during the debate i would my confidence
would be with desantis during the debate
because his disciplinary you know his
aura when it comes to discipline when
whereas trump he should have just
steamrolled through this sure and he
just didn't because he got distracted
and decided to just you know talk [ __ ]
if ron desantis
does not run in 2024 it will be the
biggest mistake of his life it'll be the
biggest mistake the gop ever made not
headlining and front-running ron
desantis uh you have a guy who is
answering joe biden on a nightly basis
he's calling out jen sackey on a nightly
basis although he's running a state
he is having national conversations on a
nightly basis and he's being proven
right over and over and over again the
dems are good down and donald trump
is going to rally the other people's
base in a way that ron desantis won't
the crazies that came out against trump
won't come out against ron desantis he
won't activate them
trump will okay and i lived through it
with chris christie i lived through it
if christy ran
all right on a national level when he
was in his first term he was a superstar
he was a hero he couldn't do anything
wrong he had worked across the aisle he
had worked with cory booker he had saved
newark he brought zuckerberg and
facebook into into jersey and then his
second term was a nightmare it was a
disaster and his career has by the way i
cannot tell you how much i agree with
gerard
there's there's so much value in what
gerard you you just said right now
because this whole thing about running
is about timing
and he's got everything on his side
right after he ran today who knows
what's going to happen four years from
that's a very good point you're making
george great argument why did you run
when you know you're not beating trump
there's nothing
he just said but he just said it like
you're not activating the people that
are just like well i don't care about
policies i'm just going to vote against
trump part of the deal donald here's the
deal you only got four years anyway
let's make a deal you've got kids that
they they want you want to be in
the you want to be in the room you want
to be in the meetings we need you out
there we need you as a cheerleader we
need you as a cheerleader for ron and
the idea is donald trump
possibly believe the word coming out of
your mouth right now dude there's no way
you believe what you're saying right now
you see you see
trump has an explanation for ron
desantis
trump cares about one person and one
person only and that's himself but he's
and that's fine i don't think that's
true
i don't think that's
you're about to say right now i think he
cares about the trump name i think he
cares about the trump name and as long
as his name is in front of it i think
the gop could make a legacy play to
donald trump i think they can make a
legacy play i think you're wrong but i
respect your opinion for being real fair
enough
and i'm telling you if ron desantis if
desantis is listening to this and you're
going to be talked into waiting your
turn
do not i think trump would be interested
if ron desantis changes his name to don
desantis that's the only way that donald
trump is gonna give two shits about
desantis yeah let me let's go so okay go
there go there who's the only person
trump's gonna listen to to have that
conversation with them and sell them on
it the only person only person who who's
gonna listen there's nobody millie
mattis his wife his kids i think i think
you can you'd have to get to
ivanka and don junior and you'd have to
get to them and and and they would have
to they wouldn't that that would be the
the ultimate sign of this lawsuit
but you're asking donald trump
donations they make a ton of money off
of merch trump
here's my opinion if he's already a
billionaire he doesn't give a [ __ ]
listen there's a deal to me other than
the the good job let me just let me just
talk some sense for a second i know that
um you know we're getting heated with
some rhetoric here
other than the good job
uh desantis john over the last 18 months
why would donald trump care about
desantis at all point b to that donald
trump wants himself to be there in 2024
and then on a way lesser level sure he
wants another trump to be there after
that i agree with the second so he
doesn't care
about a desantis a pence do you think
nikki haley he wants himself there in
2022 you guys think and you know that's
it actually liked being president of the
united states he liked the title of it
yeah okay he didn't like doing the job
day in and day out he actually liked the
job he liked it so much that he will run
again
i think he's got unfinished business and
he just he loves he is a showman he does
not like he's losing and he wants to i
think there's a deal to be made man no
we're gonna win so much that you're
gonna get sick of winning and he got
sick of winning yeah and he lost and now
he wants to win the guy needs a show
every night on tv the guy needs a show
every night
he needs to be on
in between tucker and hannity every
night he'd pull first of all he'd pull a
six rating every freaking night he'd
make more money than anybody in the
history you mean
you think he'd have more viewers than
don lemon
let you see the numbers that just came
in by the way rachel maddow just got a
30 million dollar deal can you pull that
up rachel maddow from msnbc
got a 30 million dollar deal
inside a massive msnbc deal payne maddow
to work less 30 million dollar annually
while ending her show next year and
giving their top star a more flexible
schedule than ever before aggressive
dream right there 30 million
management rachel maddow the
you send me the text you send me does
kai have that it should be it's in the
it's just
to show the ratings the different stats
if you got that pull that up to talk
about who's doing what that is crazy
she got a 30 million 30 million yeah and
you should see the views by the way like
how many views
they're getting versus others for her to
get a dirty 30 million dollar contract
so how often do you listen to her from
each their capacity to what's their
necessity no but do you ever listen to
her hi dan and my day with rachel maddow
you don't i uh i don't listen to her
that often but i i'll like i do i only
do youtube now that's all i do i haven't
had a tv in two years times were tough
bro i had to cut the cord and i saved
that money
but since i moved to dallas and i lived
in that uh beautiful apartment you
recommended i've only watched youtube so
i watch a lot of clips
whether it's tucker whether it's rachel
maddow who's that beauty the cover of
what is it i don't i don't get that i
don't get that cnn spent nearly 80 of
september
under 1 million viewers seriously
what the liberal network saw a 41 drop
from september 2020
uh
new cycle and
president joe biden took office but cnn
doesn't appear to be reaping a benefit
cnn has a dismal september fallen nearly
1 million viewers on any of its program
of its programs for 23 out of 30 days in
a month equating two staggering 77 last
september the final weeks of 2020
elections cnn averaged 950 000
total day viewers this september network
average 557 primetime viewership has
virtually cut in half during the same
time from 1.5 million to 770 000 but but
show the one that gerard has show the
one that gerard has can we see the most
watched programs or that's the one i
want the one that was
the comparative analysis do you have it
if you have that pull that up but you
were saying you listen to rachel maddow
everything no i don't i don't i'll watch
clips and she's certainly the um
the front runner over at msnbc it's not
so what's their lineup that um you got
joy read rachel madden now joey's not on
at night is she well they have they have
lawrence o'donnell right after her
they've got brian williams i really like
brian williams before her they got um
uh i like brian williams chris chris
hayes all right so check this out enjoy
reading before christine hang on to joe
reed and roland sorry again join cnn's
entire primetime lineup in a fallen
falling below the humiliating line of
one million dollar viewers joy has fewer
viewers than the shows before and after
her don lemon and anderson cooper barely
getting 500
i thought anderson cooper almost no no
viewers
click on it click on it to see it
so uh four o'clock cavuto 1.7 million
tapper 731 wallace one point two six six
yeah
five is the number one show out of
everybody five's hilarious it is a
little shout out to tyrus yeah old pro
wrestler yeah i do love them 2.8 five
seven five is the number one show five
p.m then it's tapper again 646.
uh
1.963
blitzer
is at what 567 you see at 6 00 pm that's
the new star on msnbc that's ari
melbourne he's he's pretty corny and he
tries to rap sometimes
he's not bad he's a he's a smart
attorney
primetime 1.87 burnett 602 reid
979 carlson 2.601 the 5 is beating
carlson wow cooper 638 hayes 1.214
that's chris right 1.214
and then you got hannity 2.343
cooper 570
uh what's that one tr ms the rachel
maddow the rachel maddow show okay
uh
and then you got the ingram 1.1915
lemon 528 so who's the low side amongst
everybody here
he is the lowest amongst everybody
here's actually what you have to do
because obviously on the on this
three
headed monster you have fox news as the
only thing right of center wait wait let
me stay on that stay on that fine and
then you'll keep going
can i can i stay on that and then you
have cnn left of center and then you
have arguably msnbc
left of cnn so i know what i would say
today so i'm just saying you have to com
like they're eating into each other's
market shares can i tell you something
you find something okay
here's what i would say
at tapper and wallace together
yes fight is destroying right at the
beat and blitzer bear is still beating
those two combined yes reed and burnett
is losing to prime time haze and cooper
is getting destroyed by carlson
uh rachel maddow and cooper are getting
destroyed by hannity last word and
lamont are still losing to ingram
williams and lemon the only person the
only one that's beating the other side
is tapper and wallace combined
yeah so if you combine the two yeah so
even so if you say there's the top three
political shows msnbc cnn fox
fox single-handedly is still beating the
other guys if you think about it so what
does that mean in the big picture of
things
i think there still means 46 percent are
going to vote republican 40 no 44
percent is going to do republican for 42
is going to do republican 44 is going to
do damage whatever the number is 12 in
the middle three is going to do this i
think you're really dealing with 10 or
12 percent nothing's changed i disagree
with that completely i think that what
this tells you is that the future is
completely and totally up for grabs i
think that this is i i agree with that i
agree with that because there's nobody
now how many i would love to know what
the average person at nine o'clock
is doing as far as age is doing under 25
years old yeah why are they watching how
are they watching if anyone under 35
years old is watching any of this yeah
any of this because if you're if you're
18 to 30 you're watching youtube you're
not even on this crowd tick tock youtube
listen
you got to realize all those numbers are
great rogan destroys them russell brand
destroys them i mean you can go so many
different shows that are podcasts that
are doing stuff that are killing these
guys but rachel maddow makes 30 a year
okay
30 year and what does rogan do rogan
gets 100 million dollar contract with uh
spotify with uh spotify i had a uh
i had a video on tick tock get two
million views uh yesterday and i get
taken down today
well that seems to be pretty normal for
you why are you surprised that your
stuff gets taken down at this point
seriously
i'm just happy you got two million views
for a punishment yeah yeah
you got you got the s m thing going on
see you later buddy i see he had the
whistleblower just go up that's what it
was
like
that was fun
asked a question here let's let's
process this somebody give 50 and ask a
good question here so flat rate
inspection i'm a solo a solo
entrepreneur 400 000 year income as a
home inspector and a single dad home
inspector single dad okay
nine to one the odds of being a single
mom versus a single dad for every one
single dad there's nine single moms just
so you know this is not common okay
my question is simple do you think it is
easier to be a man and a father today or
a man and a father 50 years ago
technology considered what do you think
asking a bunch of guys who have no kids
george what do you think
quiet here
i think it's easier today why do you
think i think um if you were a single
dad back in the day
where are you making money or not making
money because obviously money will help
any situation this question with a
single dad and he's making money
yeah right it's a single okay working
right yeah things everything is a lot
easier today because all right my kid's
hungry all right just get the pampers
order them i don't have to run out of
the house worry put them in the car seat
everything's just at the tip of your
finger you can order you could order you
could order you can order a nanny online
just to come in and help you so if
you've got money things are a lot my one
of my best friends is a single dad he's
the he's a he's he's that guy what do
you say the 10
and he's not
life ain't that hard for him i mean it's
he's he's raised his daughter she's
doing great he's a money guy he's got
money he's doing okay he's like 400k
type of a guy uh he's
no but he's he's all right but obviously
if you're making
400k which is right at the tax threshold
that biden's looking for you're doing
all right
um but when you say
it's easier so when you say raising kids
we're talking about like not just the
convenience of
pampers and food we're talking about
like instilling values and [ __ ] so like
i definitely believe that like back in
the day
it would it would be as far as easier
yeah you could say today but there's a
lot of people that are just like here's
the ipad son go go play that's true so
there's that easiness but does that help
the kids so now we're in a different
question very good question you know
very very good question for me it's like
okay
um you know i was you know i've been
married right so i helped raise another
man's kid he was 10 years old at the
time
would i say it was it would be easier
today no
because there's too much [ __ ] going on
i was definitely involved and made sure
that you know homework this net go
outside play
those things were happening it wasn't
like oh go play with your ipad
but it required
more of an effort of an effort back then
yeah but men back then actually made the
effort
back then and
are you saying that they're not making
the effort now what do kids learn from
their fathers today
i don't know what do you mean what are
you saying like do these mothers aren't
teaching their kids most kids don't even
know how to change a tire
i don't know how to change a tire there
you go
but i'm saying like there's certain
things that men back then when we're
saying back then we're talking about
like men had to know like do they even
teach wood shop and [ __ ] in schools and
stuff like kids back then had male
figures that taught them things you're
saying that that men today have been
emasculated i'm not saying emasculated
i'm saying that what are they actually
physically teaching their kids
physically teaching them because of the
convenience of they're saying like oh
well we can order this difference
between changing tires and
um
wood shop i mean that 50 years ago that
was a man a change of tire these days
just take a [ __ ] uber like it's not
you know it's things have changed but
there's good and bad but there's still
lessons in these things of being
resourcefulness i feel you on that so so
back in the day i mean we all had an
uncle or a father or grandfather that
taught us certain things that made us
become more resourceful i think with
with technology we're not as resourceful
as we think we just went through the
whole facebook thing
people weren't resourceful during that
time period people kept literally people
kept doing this it's not working it's
not working yeah it's not working
especially for the person they wasted
six hours they wasted
they wasted six hours of their time
back then yeah but you didn't know how
to work let me tell you there was a meme
that used to have back in the day this
thing right here and you see a picture
of
an alarm clock and a cell phone a uh
how far you walk a calculator a
flashlight
all that stuff and more is all right
here but that [ __ ] didn't matter that
that stuff like even right now like a
lot of those things that we become so
accustomed to using is it does it really
matter first of all you know i
interviewed this guy a couple days ago
david what was his name dr
warren farrell dr warren farrell not
will ferrell dr warren farrell and he
wrote a book called the boy crisis new
york times best-selling guy former
feminist he was earlier you know with
the feminist founder
former feminist and he says feminism has
changed over the years
before it was equal opportunity for men
and women today it's i've been wrong so
men are this so it's so he's like my
position hasn't changed the movement of
feminism has changed but my position
hasn't changed on what it was back in
the 60s and 70s and he wrote this book
and some of the stuff that he talked
about in
his speech that he gave with tedx we
were talking he said at the age of nine
the suicide rate amongst boys and girls
is equal at the age of nine
from 10 or 14 it doubles boys to girls
10 or 14. 15 to 19 it's four x
boys two girls
twenty boys are committed four times the
amount of boys commit suicide than girls
do
20 to 25 is six times more
boys to girls
then he went a little bit deeper he says
uh so the challenge is the fact that men
boys do better when they're around their
fathers than they are around their
mothers
boys need fathers more than girls need
their fathers you know you hear
sometimes the whole thing where for
girls there's some daddy issues and you
know when you're dating her she's kind
of looking at you as a daddy he's
talking about boys need a male figure in
their lives okay so he talks about the
benefit of a boy wrestling with his
father his dad straightening them up you
know you know mom you can negotiate and
say but dad you know he deserves okay
let him it's okay baby we said dad's
gonna say no you don't get this done
you're not gonna get that right certain
values and principles he said we one of
the biggest problems is we don't have
male teachers is what he talked about
he said we need more male teachers
interesting
we
teachers and examples to challenge
somebody like if you think about it
yourself maybe your male teacher was one
of your coaches yeah that toughened you
up so maybe it's not a teacher maybe
it's a coach roll that place right and
then he went on to talk about the fact
that the tax incentives
changed in the 50s and 60s where back in
the days there weren't that many single
mothers tax incentive
change where mother women said i don't
need a man to raise a kid i don't need a
man to raise a kid i can do it myself
because i'm getting a tax
incentive work child tax credit
and then he also went a little bit
deeper talking about the fact that 50 60
years ago
you know there was still a need for
women to need a protection and safety so
there was an element of no i'm not going
to get a divorce today the divorce rate
of women filing divorce men filing
divorce is very similar it wasn't like
that before there wasn't a lot of
divorce taking place because it wasn't
it was a equal exchange today the
exchange is not equal today women don't
need men because they can go make their
own money so it's kind of like listen i
you want to do this you don't want to do
this i'm okay i'm going to go and do my
own thing you figure it out so a lot of
these dynamics have also changed in the
last 50 years so the guy asking a
question he's right it is a different
dynamic today than it was before but uh
based on what this guy was talking about
you may want to read that book
the boy crisis whoever is reading this
and you may want to read the book
raising up boys those two books i would
recommend to you i read raising up boys
when i had my first son fantastic book i
don't think you talked about whether you
have a daughter or a son
i think he just said the fact that he
has a baby right did he say his son
a man uh uh father yeah he didn't talk
about boy or girl but by the same author
that wrote raising our boys also wrote
raising up girls so it is different
times today than before you are the only
one here with full-on kids i know you
said you've raised a step-son
you've got four kids now yeah tico's ten
nine nine dylan's seven eight eight
seven is five and a brooklyn story
brooklyn's zero 13 months she's what
she's 13 months
i'm sorry 13 weeks my probably just 13
weeks i'm like 31
yeah
you said nine ten years ago okay social
media wasn't what it was life has been
you didn't have money then
at that point you weren't crushing it 10
years ago were you what's money
all right that's such a pvd response
well what do you mean by money like
you're not where you are now you were
you're in startup mode right big
difference between lifestyle but i'm
still out of half 2010 you were i'm
still making money yeah but you put
everything into p
no no give me breakdown money yeah but
you find money like are you saying okay
on a scale of one to ten where's your
money now versus where it was then no no
no no yeah no no how concerned were you
that you were gonna pay i haven't been
worried about money since may of 2004.
okay awesome yeah then thank you there
you go my point is this the world has
changed in the last 10 years social
media everything that's happened
politically what have you how how has
parenting changed from your first kid
to your fourth kid
i don't think it's changed much for us
that's not a big enough of a difference
in nine years okay i think the
difference is our era to the 20 year
olds today like a david yep versus my
kids i think it's i think it's 20 years
is how you engage it i don't think 10
years is enough to gauge the difference
so then answer the initial question
parenting changed
is it easier to be a dad today what what
was his question
versus 50 years ago is it i'm going to
tell you what there's there's a um
you're going to let him answer it it's
tough to answer that question because i
don't think you'd be a single father 50
years ago
i think it's a different world today but
if you were if you were 50 years ago
versus today it's probably going to be
harder 50 years ago than today the part
that's going to be tougher today is the
way the dad decides to be an involved
dad versus not involved that like
there's many ways you can make parenting
easy today you got a shitload of
distractions they're so easy to be a
parent today but to be a father who's
leading his kids that's a lot harder
today than 50 years ago
it's a lot harder today than 50 years if
you want to be a true father that's
leading your kids that's right because
50 years ago how did you get your porn
how did you get your porn when you were
14 years old i've never seen it i'm
surprised
some of your friends that got porn
magazines okay yeah it was magazines
what when you were 14 years old
okay and by the way even if it was
magazine give me the most hardcore thing
you ever saw in a magazine
here we go hardcore what are you going
to see
there's no way in the world you saw it
all
14 years old and house hustler penthouse
hustler wasn't that hard whatever they
had what do you know what's today's
hardcore you know what i didn't live in
chatsworth in two thousand i don't know
we were baptizing chatsworth
in the name of rhonda
what i'm trying to say is there's way
more content today to psychologically
mess with a kid's mind today facts
so if you want to just be a father
have sex have a kid you just let them be
distracted by an ipad for 18 years you
can easily do it today with video games
but you're raising a leader it's just a
kid
it's a very very different uh mindset
you have 100 on the effort you got to
put in 50 years ago people lived with
their family unit more too so even if
you were a single dad chances were that
your family unit was very very close by
you had sisters cousins aunts uncles
mother father very very close within
that community as well
there wasn't the
idea of my sister lives in
chicago my father lives in in boston i
live you know what i'm saying like the
family unit was
geographically closer so you'd have more
of an insulated you know uh
um you know support system one of the
things that you have to deal with today
that's very very difficult though and we
just saw this with the you know election
the the education secretary cardona uh
the state is trying to take over control
of your kids that's not something you
had to deal with 50 years ago you didn't
have they they literally asked he was at
a uh judicial senate judicial hearing
committee and they said who who is i
forget who the senator was asked the
biden secretary of education who is the
primary stakeholder
in a child's education the guy wouldn't
answer one and a half million people
have taken their kids out of public
schools in the last year and a half
because of differences in political
ideologies and what they feel like is
extremism being taught in public schools
and then the guy won't answer and the
the senator doubles down and goes does
the parent have the primary right to
make decisions over a child's education
and the guy finally circles back and
says no the state the state has just as
much of a right this is a community
issue
he won't say that the parent is the
primary stakeholder in a child's
education children your kids that guy's
kids are a cultural battleground
that's the they're this is the the kids
are battleground so therefore back in
the day
do you think
like when we're talking about parents
you think they put up with that now
yeah those parents no no way no way i
can't see my i can't see you can't see
your granddad or father any teacher or
any administrator ever in a million
years
telling my grandfather you know we have
more of a say over your child's
education than you do my grandfather
would have done things to that
administrator that would be you know
years in jail today years in jail for
sure there's no way there's no way that
they would have even had the the gall
and wherewithal you know and this guy
was a you know he was a a local 40 iron
worker you know he he liked education
but he didn't even really care he's like
joining union with us we don't really
care you know like you know the school
is school was daycare for them you know
he knew all my uncles were going to join
the union with him so school was daycare
he didn't really care but if they tried
to tell him how to raise his kids
essentially he would get his literal
irish up and that would have been the
end of that for sure so for the
education secretary to sit there for the
whole world to say and see and say not a
state has more of a say than than the
parents do i mean how do you take that
like you said you're kidding me do you
realize what that does to me when you
say something like that i mean it's just
pathetic to make it come and that's
exactly what they want to do they would
like to be able to do that and you as a
parent have to not fall for that
you as a parent has to be involved you
as a parent has to be have to be so
involved with the kid where you don't
lose your kid too many parents are
losing their kids because they're not
involved enough what do you mean what do
you mean by losing their kids he just
said like with the ipad with the being
distracted doing all those things you're
not being participating but they're
losing your culture so let me let me
explain to you let me explain how this
thing works i read a book years ago
called thank god it's monday right and
thank god it's monday it's this guy
who's a psychologist so talking about
how most men in america cannot wait for
it to be monday to get the hell away
from the wife and the kids because they
want to be away they want to be free
they're saying thank god it's monday
rather than thank god it's friday
because friday the whole weekend and the
kids and the babysitting stuff starts
right so he's saying he watched all this
stuff with marriages what was
problematic and he said what i found out
relationships and marriages and parents
that worked
they gave individual time to their kids
regularly so if you're married you come
home you talk to your wife 10 minutes
how was your day babe you go to 10
minutes one on one right then you go to
your kids so tell me how was your day
101 then you find out one of them needs
a little bit more time then you go and
talk to them for 10 or 15 minutes or
one-on-one that one-on-one time takes
effort and most parents don't want to do
that that one-on-one time takes effort
it's just like in sales that one-on-one
time with your client that one-on-one
time on follow-up that one-on-one time
of writing the card to them most people
don't want to put that effort no so
parents are losing their kids because
they're not having that one-on-one
conversation with their kids that's
right that's why i said when the guy
asks a question he's right it takes a
lot more work and effort today than it
did before because you have more things
to question you have to be more vigilant
you have to be today you have to be more
passionate
you have to be more passionately
passionately present with your own
offspring these are your offspring well
he's the one that holds your legacy
and like what pat's saying i mean you
know we've all seen pat with his family
and stuff and he does a great job you
know he's very involved you know but how
many parents are actually doing those
things and then like you said it it
requires effort you're supposed to grow
them
but you're not feeding them no it's not
it's not easy man it's listen that's why
i understand the argument today of not
having a kid i fully understand the
argument of not having a kid when people
make the argument of not having a kid i
get it you're better off not having a
kid
that you're not going to put time into
than having a kid
and you know
saying i don't have time to put the time
into because you're just helping out the
institution more okay that it's tell you
don't do it then then you're right i
respect the person that says like you
know i sat down with a guy okay one of
the most powerful cfos in america today
he was in aig cfo when they went to the
government and raised 183 billion
dollars successful guy within five years
or six years they pay back the 183 plus
21 billion dollars of interest they were
the first to pay back aig as much as
people trash aig they paid it back gm
still hasn't paid back they paid her
back i said so how long you been married
we've been married for 30 some years 20
some years so how many kids you guys got
we don't have any kids why not my wife
and i chose 30 years ago that our
careers are kids
okay so now when a person hears that
what do they say what a freaking [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] why would you make your kid
you know it's a then another person will
say i would never do such a thing maybe
not a [ __ ] and another person may say
well what if they actually sat down and
talked about the fact that
they're not going to be able to put the
time into their kids that they'd like
and it's not fair for the kid okay great
that's actually better processing there
is a form of processing that if you
don't put into it right no look look at
china today look at the statistic with
china today kai can you pull up that
article i sent you that said within 45
years have you guys seen this yeah like
their population will be cut in half
right cut in half did you see this
article it did not no yeah i just sent
it to you guys earlier today i don't
know if you had a chance to take a look
at it china's population could have
within the next 45 years new study warns
china's population could have like cut
in half within the next 45 years
researchers say previous estimates
may have severely underestimated the
pace of democratic democrat fake decline
census uh data says the birth rate was
1.3 children for each woman last year
well below the level needed to stop the
population from fall and go a little
lower you said it's 2.4 is what is u.s
is no 2.4 is for it to grow to grow 1.3
1.7 is level off gotcha 2.4 2.3 you're
growing china's population decline may
be much faster than expect the number of
people in the country having
uh within the next 45 years the
projection was based on the rate birth
of 1.3 yeah so but anyways going back to
the conversation we're having
if you're not going to put the time in
the kids man you know just you may want
to skip it's a lot of work today i
actually have a question for phil as a
black man
um
i i
we were talking about watching different
news sources someone that's i'll tend to
watch sometimes is candace owens i don't
know if you have any strong feelings pro
or against her whatever but what she she
was speaking on a panel one time
um and i remember she was having a
debate with t.i the rapper i think i saw
that okay and she said something to the
effect of the biggest
epidemic going on in america today well
in the black community is the absence of
the black father
and basically saying that's why she
doesn't mess with feminism at all
because uh you know it's a breakdown of
the nuclear family and then and that it
basically and i don't know that exact
number i'm sure i'll get it wrong but it
was like
it was like 75 of uh a young black
american african-american men are raised
a lot of father it could be less could
be more but it was certainly more than
50 i don't remember the exact number and
she read a quote
by someone
saying
uh i had a father i was raised with a
father and you have father and the quote
was from tupac one of your um
um
heroes on your uh on your
painting the point is this
um as a black man you were definitely
raised with a good family i'm sure
you've have some stories on this what
are your thoughts on
americans living without a father in
their life well my parents divorced when
i was three oh okay i didn't know that
right so i didn't hang out with my
biological father
uh very often it was more like uh
you know a handful of times here and
there
birthday and christmas definitely he
always made sure of those things okay um
but uh he was kind of absent for
majority of the time and then it wasn't
up until like i was grown that we
started reestablishing a relationship
however
he was taken
he passed away seven years ago so around
that time that was like i felt cheated
but you know i was raised by my
stepfather and my mom
but they both worked
so they both worked a lot so i was
basically raising myself
at the age of eight nine years old
cooking cleaning for myself you know i
was a you know shoestring key kid i was
one of those guys
um
luckily i didn't burn the house down but
you know i had a lot of discipline in
the house and my mom definitely would
have whipped my ass if i would have done
something stupid
but as far as like uh
being taught how to do certain things
you know i did have that available my
family was high on education one of my
step my stepfather he who is still alive
he he had other kids that were much
older than i am but he made sure that we
always had a personal computer in the
house he was very interested in you know
technology he worked as a tv engineer
for uh nbc affiliate king five
television in seattle washington so you
you had your stepfather in your life i
had my step father and my father was
doing his thing yeah you know um what
about the the the bigger picture for you
know african-americans you know i
definitely feel that it's imperative for
let's just call it what it is i mean
any family dynamic requires a mother and
a father for to raise these kids
absolutely
um
but what candice i believe was saying
that the the absentee father
is creating a big problem
for the african
american community when you're talking
about you just can't have women raising
these kids and expect them to have
exponential growth and be competitive in
the workplace you know they're missing
out on half of what the other kids are
having
period so i definitely think it's
imperative and when you know the
incarcerations of you know
african-american males and you know drug
addictions and these things
you know you have to just play life with
your eyes and realize like use common
sense i mean how is the kid going to
respond
there's only many so many success
stories of a woman having a kid
you know
even in their teens or early on and
thinking like wow i can only i can do
this by myself no she's going to require
a ton of help my best friend my best my
best friend who you'll meet um his mom
you know shoot she had him when she was
like 15.
and the dad was not around but he's one
of those kids that actually you know had
help you know had a you know a lot of
family around
and um you know he's killing it you know
he's you know executive with aws you
know doing very well for himself but not
every person has that story
there's not most people don't most
people don't think so it's definitely
well they don't but they wouldn't if it
was you know let's just call it what it
is if there's another ethnicity or white
folks if if if the tables were turned
it's just people
yeah it's just people at the end of the
day you know you take the you take the
white man out of the kid's life you know
you talk about like uh you know and
excuse me if i say this but like you
know trailer park guys or this that or
or white dudes that just you know
at the end of the day it's just people
you take the male out of the family and
he's non-existent with these kids
especially for a young male
a woman can only do so much shout out to
all the single moms right that have sons
but if they could have it where those
single moms could have a strong man in
their life number one the woman
definitely needs compassionate you know
they need a man
okay they need a partner
but these young boys need men they need
to understand like certain things
they're missing out on they're missing
out on certain aspects of life in my
opinion this world is tough man and it's
even tougher when you're alone dude and
i tell you you know there's no doubt in
my mind
i would be
i would have been in jail without my
father
even though we don't have a great
relationship with no doubt in my mind
but i would have been able to deal with
my father if not for my mother
that i would not have been able to deal
with him if not for her running
interference and if not for him i would
have been in bad bad shape
was was a crazy wild child
you know if you think i hate authority
now you should let me let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question so
who would you have done better with if
it was just your dad or just your mom
wouldn't work either way i would have
broken my mom if my dad wasn't there i
might i would have broken her
my my
i would not have
done the right things early enough i
wouldn't have matured early enough not
to have broken her heart if my father
wasn't there and if my mother wasn't
there
it would have been an unsustainable
situation between me and my father would
have it would have come to a head and
one of us would have had to go
and and
oddly enough
they raised three kids they raised my
sisters are incredibly incredibly
intelligent successful people very like
you know allison is a marketing
executive emily's an assistant dean like
they are incredibly successful you know
very very brilliant woman
and
my parents probably
and i don't realize this until i'm an
adult
they didn't have a great relationship
they sacrificed
30 40 years of their life
probably being with the person that they
shouldn't have been with
specifically because they decided like
like the cfo decided that yeah there
they made their life about you guys they
made their life about us they never
missed a single game they we didn't take
vacations our vacations were baseball
trips to you know the regionals to
soccer on the weekends they they never
they worked their asses off my mom
worked two jobs my dad worked 60 hours a
week no vacations
our vacations were soccer tournaments
yeah you know what i'm saying and i i
gotta tell you
if you could give my father a truth
serum right now dutiful irish man well
never he said look this is what a man
does
i bet he regrets it
i bet you he thinks that that he should
have made more time for himself and his
dreams and his passions along that way i
feel like he gave up
too much of himself i feel like my mom
gave up too much of herself they made it
too much about us and they these are
incredible parents are you saying they
made the right choice
i don't i think the lesson here is some
sort of moderation that i i i don't
think they could have done any better
and especially me i did not make it easy
on them i wish i would have made it way
easier on them right
but they did as well as they could and
on a grand scheme in a grand scale they
raised a pro athlete and two incredible
incredible you know these successful
females right
but there's a reason me and my sisters
aren't married this was a this was a
tough relationship we saw a lot of
fighting well there's still hope for you
buddy you're 35 years old you'll do okay
look i understand
but it's there's a reason to it and
there's a reason why this generation's
not getting married there's a reason we
are living longer i think i think
there's a lot more options out there
you've seen divorce i saw what divorce
did to my uncle i saw my uncle
go go to work i saw my uncle my
godfather god rest his soul work
60 hours a week
living on his sister's couch while
another man lived in his house with his
ex-wife that man refused to marry my
aunt because as soon as they got married
my uncle would be off the hook on
alimony yep so
seven years this man my uncle
essentially financed another man
being in his house with his wife
so why would you want to be married you
know what i'm saying so listen i got a
number for a therapist for you dude
we're gonna have you call we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna set you up all
jokes aside therapy save my freaking
water so if anybody out there that's not
a joke i cannot advocate for therapy as
much as possible dvd you were raised
by do you tell the story that your
your parents were married they had um
paulette divorced got back together had
you another divorce
left iran
germany l.a yeah
where would you be yeah with your
parents listen i agree with them
on on on on uh what do you call it if
you look at a
data wise they shouldn't have gotten
married they they should have not gotten
married realized communism they just
should have gotten married my mom was a
beautiful she would be a model today
tall attractive she
performed you know she was an athlete
ping-pong she got a four-year degree in
a time that women didn't get a four-year
degree my math comes from my mom's side
my mom gave me my math genetics and then
my dad on the other side was a man's man
who was a guy that kept his word and
respected and valued by everybody but he
was a romantic guy like if you ask him
right now who's what are our favorite
movies you know what i'll say notebook
anything with natalie wood anything
would happen
hallmark classics oh he likes dr zhivago
too yeah yeah yeah
he's probably watched the graduate i
don't know how many times he's probably
watched you know the thing for older
women he probably watched he's 79. how
much older can he get you know
he's into 100 year old woman
elizabeth you know i don't know about
that
but but you know what but you know what
there's another part to it here man
there's another part to it here that
we're not thinking about that i think
you got to be thinking about as well by
the way appreciate you for opening
government i was i felt that i totally
felt that what you were talking i hope
your parents and your sisters see this
like i hope if you know his parents and
his sister forward this to him because
he's not going to do it but
mom dad whatever you guys did you guys
did a good job with this guy because we
love this guy but me let me let me say
this part two that we don't give enough
value to
um
dude we don't know which person we are
in our
lineage we don't know who we are meaning
you look at i watch the documentary you
read obama's story or kennedy's story
and you see
joseph kennedy has his oldest son joe
and he's planning to build him to be the
president and he ends up going to war
and he dies as a fighter pilot and he
was the guy that was supposed to be then
the kid who had back problems his entire
life who was the youngest one that
nobody expected and the father gave up
on life after the oldest son died he was
depressed for years and the guy that he
least expected to be the president ends
up becoming the president and then you
watch the documentary trumpster there is
the grandfather who comes in who has
restaurants and parlors and all this
stuff i think in alaska out of all the
places literally i think in alaska and
then he
has his son fred trump who moves to
jersey new york he makes us money and
then the grandfather didn't know that
his grandson was one day gonna be the
billionaire and
be the president that you don't know the
sacrifice you none of us know what the
hell we're here until we die it's going
to take a long time for you to really
realize your purpose sometimes
god's using you to be the person that
he's counting on for this generation to
do something big with but sometimes he's
using you to breed the person that's
going to end up breeding the person
that's going to end up breeding the
person that's going to be the best
president we've ever had and the
grandfather is never going to know about
it one of the chapels i want to saw in
venice they said this place took 330
years to build the first engineer that
wrote out the map and the the wrote out
the what do you call it the the plan the
plan
the architecture
he knew what he was building his great
great great great great great great
grandkid was never gonna see it can you
imagine you got a vision that you built
something that you're never gonna
fulfill
we forget that sometimes we're just
gonna come and go and it's okay bro be
patient you're just playing a role in
something much bigger that you don't
know about then maybe you if you're
lucky if you are lucky
to see
a part of that become a reality whether
you're being used in a big way or if you
see it happening to your kid and your
grandkid i consider you the luckiest man
or woman alive but if you don't dude you
served your purpose in a different way
wow you just gotta do you so we don't
know this kind of stuff you know we
sometimes we sit there because we tell
stories like this and i sit and talk to
my dad and my dad will go and say
you know he was in love with this one
girl or he wasn't like my dad's a
romantic he's a big time romantic guy
and you know he's he's so i said okay
but he says you know he says to me
lately he says but i tell you what man
if i didn't do that you wouldn't be here
paula wouldn't be here and look where
life would have been and you know i'm so
glad i married your mother because i
didn't even know what was taking place
and so guys
as as smart as an intellectual and crazy
we sound and all this [ __ ] we talk
we don't have a clue what they we got to
do our best with our life that's right
and there's a part of it that you got to
rely on the man upstairs to see what his
plans are and whether you believe in god
or not there's a part of me that just
kind of like you know you still don't
know what's going to happen you don't
know you're going to go
uh to louis bossie and you're going to
walk up and the host is going to look at
you you're going to look at her and all
of a sudden you're going to talk to her
and you guys going to exchange numbers
you're going to go to dinner with her
and all of a sudden you're going to be
like i feel something special with this
kid i don't know what the hell is going
i don't even like the feeling i've got
any going to break up with her and she's
going like what are you doing you have a
feeling for me why are you doing this to
yourself six months 12 months are you
going to come up to me and say pat can
we have a cigar we go to the house well
up to three o'clock in the morning and
you say pat i got feelings for but i'm
scared man we're having that
conversation then you marry her then you
have a kid then you're 82 years old your
son ends up running becoming the
president and we read about it when
we're dead
you don't know this kind of stuff that's
why you just gotta sometimes
you know you gotta let it come to you
you gotta rather than sometimes we put
so much effort before it's happening
instead of gotta dance man we gotta
dance sometimes we gotta learn how to do
this crazy question for you yeah staying
on topic but a little off topic you
talked about the guy who built the the
thing and then his grandkids and his
grandkids and i just posted something on
instagram today and i want to open it up
for everyone is
would you want to live forever no no no
way no way you would not no there's a
lot of people that do nowadays i have no
desire to do that so jeff bezos is
trying to right so yeah
longevity right i think i think i would
want to live to piggyback on what you're
saying real quick
i think um the moral historian guys and
and everybody watching is life has no
rehearsal
life has no rehearsal so you got to live
it and test first lessons yeah and you
have to you have to be courageous and
you have to know that like it's all
about leaving your mark you know uh one
of the things that i would do when i
would train for the olympia is uh there
was two routes that i would take and one
was just more of like a city route and
one was more like the country route i
used to take the country out and people
say why
there was a uh
a cemetery that i had to drive by every
time they go to the gym and why would i
go buy that
just think about that for a second
what's going on to let you know that
you're gonna be there i'm gonna be in
that dirt and every time i would drive
by i look over to the left and i see
people celebrating i see people mourning
i see people screaming man i sell it all
and at the end of the day i used to be
like
okay when you buried your father phil
what did you feel
you'd see his name and you remind
yourself of who he was to you and this
and that and then you realize like
you're gonna be in there as well where
am i going with this
i want to earn that spot man mm-hmm and
i want to have someone to be like that
was philip gerard heath
and he was a bad dude
okay
j-e-r-r-o-d well the reason i reason i
bring this up this weekend is going to
be the two year anniversary of my
father's death so i'm planning on like
seeing my family and visiting the
gravesite
if you think you had a bad relationship
with your dad
hold my beer buddy like me and my dad
literally would get in fist fights
like like well i don't try to fight like
these days i've already been in a
thousand fist fights with my father
insane but um
so that's sentimental anyway shifting
gears but i was watching an interview
with um larry king and neil degrasse
tyson if you know he's the famous
astrologist
and degrasse tyson asked larry king
before because he's dead now so
obviously a few years ago he says would
you want to live forever and
just like that larry king says yes what
about you
uh degrasse tyson very interesting said
no and i'll tell you why he said if you
know you're going to live forever why do
you need to get up at the get up uh sure
you know get out of bed every morning
what's your goal
what makes people great is kind of like
what you're saying is knowing that your
time on earth is limited
and to seize the day and to seize the
moment every single day because you've
got this one life to make something
happen if you know you're going to live
forever dracula type vibes
what do you you know ah tomorrow you say
the number one quality of a ceo is
urgency getting [ __ ] done so we all have
this one life that's the number one
quality of
a leading range of a leader change of
creating change in your company okay but
there's other qualities for ceo but i
see what you're saying urgency is very
big but anyway that was it that was his
answer it was that like you've got this
one opportunity and if you think you're
going to live forever like jeff bezos is
literally reportedly trying to do i
don't need to have the one life forever
but i would like to keep getting spun
back up and having another chance you
want to respawn let me get another
chance to get it right i'll get it right
this time do it right now you're [ __ ]
up big time right now yeah so like we'll
do the next time let me ask you man i
mean we have three incredibly you know
highly functioning individuals right
how do you not lose yourself like i
talked about my parents i feel like they
lost themselves in being a parent
because they wanted to be the best
parents they wanted to be the best and i
feel like they lost themselves they lost
their relationship they lost who they
were they lost their dreams when you
were chasing
you know history
you're that becomes you that becomes who
you are when you're building a company
you're building a family you're running
seven companies right now yeah how do
you not lose
who you are like does that does what i'm
saying makes sense i don't know what i'm
saying i totally agree i totally agree
and on that part there is a little bit
of a confusion today for men and parents
i totally agree
this this this like you know sometimes
you know parents say things like i gave
everything for you i did everything for
mike i wish you would have done a little
bit for yourself that's right like my
mother i wish you would have remarried
somebody yeah you know it's like i don't
want to hear about the fact that you
didn't get remarried for me i didn't
tell you not to get remarried you chose
not to get remarried and my dad's like i
didn't want to get remount like dude i i
was okay if you wanted to give us i
don't want to get remarried totally fine
with this i totally agree with that part
as well that you still
have to serve your purpose a guy asked
me a question he says you know my wife
wants me to shut down the business
i see your wife wants you to shut down
the business he says yes i said okay
what do you want to do he says i don't
know i love my wife she says shut it
down because it's too much pressure and
go and get the job and make your 000 of
your income i said i said what do you
want to do he says well this is what i
want to do i'm thinking about making her
happy and i'm going to quit my job it's
okay fine i said let me have a
conversation with both of you together
so we go and we sit down with both of
them i said so tell me what you want to
do with him i wanted to quit his
business why it's not working really
it's not working okay cool is it not
working because he's not working or you
don't think the business won't work and
you're not patient no he's working he's
doing his part but it's been a year and
i don't see it taking off okay i'm fine
do you think if he eventually does it
could take off yeah probably but right
now i would much rather have him work a
regular job and make 50 60k a year i
said let me paint a picture for you i
said are you okay
is your dream to be a business owner and
do bigger things in your life yes what
are they he talks about it i want to do
this i want to do this i want to do this
i want to do this i want to see this
happen to my wife and my kids great
would you like that to happen to him as
well and to use well i would fantastic
say you go and do what she tells you to
do fast forward you're 70 years old 75
years old and you're sitting there and
you
were forced to not pursue your dream
because your wife how do you feel about
her right now resentment yeah i said i
said what i said how do you think men
act out their resentment mm-hmm how did
you think men act out their resentment
yeah i mean that's like [ __ ] happy hour
what else what else escaping going and
visiting your family spending more time
with your friends
do you think a man with resentment is a
good father you think a good man would
resentment is a good husband no
you see all these old crotchety men and
you wonder why they're just she ruined
my
here but
uh earlier i got news okay
from the bodybuilding community okay and
we're talking about this a little bit
right now and i want to kind of come to
you because
uh oh oh and you know caroline's like
you know i think it's a good idea to
come out and come talk to phil i was on
a zoom with the board and all this other
stuff so i step out and phil and i we
have a conversation together
and a george peterson 37 years old who
was competing for i believe the 212 uh
uh mr olympia class yeah uh today uh
news comes out he's supposed to compete
this weekend he's in orlando he posted a
story just 12 hours ago
and he posted uh something on instagram
just a day ago that is eating the meal
in his room they find him dead
and a lot of different stories came back
and this is from evolution of
bodybuilding the story i was reading
about that was shared with me but uh you
know
there's a lot of things that's going on
right now phil you're in this world i'm
not in this world if you don't mind
sharing yeah that's georgia peterson at
37 years old this happened just a
beautiful physique and a really really
good man in my
my heart goes out to him
his family his sister his mother
it's tough that like when i found out
you know i was very upset
um i'm still upset
um
this one hurts pretty hard because um
you know when you go on tour together
and you know you travel the world you do
the expos you do all those things you
get to know each other a little bit
you know different than just uh hitting
each other up on social media
you get to see that that smile
was real
always smiling when he was talking and
stuff and i mean this this is i mean
look at this physique
just incredible
it is beautiful
and he worked he worked so hard and we
don't know the cause of it so you know
i'm not going to speculate
i just want to celebrate his life and
and as a human being i mean he was a
really good person and you know going
into this weekend it's it's
you know i'm not going to be attending
you know i just i just want everyone
that is attending
to celebrate george
you know
the bodybuilding community is actually
really strong and they're very resilient
when things like this happen
unfortunately they do happen
and we've had
a lot of death
within our industry over the past 18
months is it more than usual phil i
would say so you know there's a couple
guys you know a couple suicides you know
and obviously during covenant and stuff
like that yeah people weren't able to go
to the gym and that was like their you
know their thing escape their escape
exactly
um
what what bothered me the most and that
gerard was able to uh you know allow me
to have some time to chat about it was
he was by
himself and that's what i i'm i'm having
a hard time with because you know during
the week of the olympia guys i mean we
are uh
you know very very lean
and
you know we we do things you know to try
to get rid of water and stuff like that
and
you know we do a lot you know we're just
exhausted guys we're exhausted and and
the biggest thing that i always tried to
maintain was a you know a core nucleus
of of friends and uh people you know my
trainer hani rambot is actually you know
the coach of hottie chopin and a few
other guys and that are getting ready
for the show
hani um was always with me
no matter what he would watch me
he would watch me eat he watched me pose
he he just didn't leave my side just in
case if something went wrong like in
2009 not just trying to make it about
myself i had food poisoning he was there
that when the emts showed up he was
there he didn't leave
so you know i know i don't want to call
out his trainer or anything like that i
just
to be honest as a to be selfish i want
to know what happened
yeah you know i personally i just want
to know what happened and i hope that
the truth comes out
is is protocol for somebody to always be
with the person that's competing like
especially at this level
in his situation
what people don't recognize and i didn't
preface this is that
you know george used to compete in
classic and then he moved up to 212 and
in 212 uh just so everybody knows this
212 is 212 pounds
so he
you know you're normally starting off
let's just say you start off at 245
pounds you're dieting down and you know
you compete
you know and this is like a heavyweight
box or boxer you know they they got to
weigh in and stuff so you guys got to
weigh in
what i was told is that you know he was
you know
basically he was already at the top of
his weight division
and it was already going to be difficult
but you know i heard that he was a
little bit too big
and when i say too big like you know the
guy was he he maybe could have competed
in open you know
because maybe his body just wanted to be
bigger i guess you know and when i say
bigger it's not like a 225 230 yeah yeah
yeah with that maybe maybe he would be
you know better at that but he but the
fact is is that when you when you try to
suck down just like a like in wrestling
or something like that in high school
whatever you know you're trying to make
weight
and um
like without heavily speculating i just
feel like you know when you're trying to
make weight it becomes very difficult
you know you could be wearing a sauna
suit you could be doing all these other
things and you're already exhausted so
you know when the news comes out you
know when the you know hopefully we
actually get the truth you know i think
it's when i say the truth i want to know
because it's imperative that we
understand as athletes
because we are elite like we're at the
top
but i don't know how to address like
what happened without knowing what
happened just out of curiosity let me
speculate let me speculate out of
curiosity
is in back in the days
uh i remember diuretics was a big deal i
remember like one time something
happened to paul dalet you remember the
whole thing when he locked up and they
were talking about you know all this
stuff and sean ray had an incident we
even talked about it on the program i
think where he won the classic and then
it was given away i don't know what
happened something happened with yeah
they were checking for diuretic usage
and i believe that he um you know tested
positive so what is the diuretic
you know basically his heart blood heart
blood pressure meds
you know it helps you know get rid of
water
essentially it sucks it sucks everything
out of your body you've already got so
you've already got like you know no fat
left you hope that you do okay and then
if you have like a little bit of film of
water and stuff i mean just to get you
know everything dried out drying your
body yes
and you're you know you cut you can to
be quite honest you can push it
and um you know
i mean look like this is f1 you know
this isn't you know like you guys can
understand what i'm saying of course
yeah but but was it was it illegal that
became a leak was it something that was
frowned upon that mr olympia started
saying it's okay if you take it now like
they don't test for it anymore i don't
no you know there's random you know
there's rent it's random got it so you
know he wasn't this is not to say that
he was no at all exactly but i you know
i'm just going to lean on the fact that
you know
he was by himself and i and i just wish
that he wasn't and you know i can you
know and i'm not going to point blame
the trainer i'm just saying like i just
i just know like from my experience i
always had someone with me whether it be
my trainer or my girl you know someone
because
i just feel like it's very important to
monitor
anything like just and just to keep your
mind you know like because when i get
ready for the olympia
i'm so dehydrated for like three days
that my mind like i can't i can't
process thoughts
so i just need someone to kind of like
keep my mind off what would your message
be if you could convey anything to the
participants this weekend
to
for especially for i'm going to speak to
the 212 guys
you're going to go up there and you're
going to give it everything you got but
you're going to remind yourself that
george is not there and you're going to
pose for him
and in the event that um
you guys can come together
and create some type of message
to
to support one another
you do it and um
moving forward we just have to
you know we're going to always compete
at a very high level but we got to
remind ourselves that um we're not
promised anything
and um just celebrate his life because
we all got the pictures and stuff you
know i don't know what to post
yeah i don't know what to say but all i
know is that like you know he's he's
he's passed on
and i'm and i'm sad
and um you know my heart goes out to his
family
you know he has a ton of friends in our
industry
he was he was just
the nicest guy
i'm sorry man you know
but uh who who is who is protecting the
athletes there's no teams there's no
union there there's no i mean there's
five or six different organizations i
think back
to
there's something that happened in the
the last tyson fury deontay wilder fight
that hit me
so hard to my core he fired his
training his trainings
deante wilder
because they his his coroner stopped the
fight he was cut and diante wilder fired
him because he was like you need to let
me die in the ring i never quit i'm not
a quitter and his coroner stopped the
fighting deante wilder seriously said
you got to let me die and
i go out on my on my shield and that hit
me so hard because i feel the i felt the
exact same way if when i was in the
minor leagues adam i [ __ ] you not if you
told me gerard here's a pill and if you
take this pill you're going to the major
leagues but you're going to die at 40. i
would have taken it without even
thinking twice i would have gobbled it
before you could have even described any
the anything outside of my immediate
goal was so abstract than anything i
wanted bro you're locked down i would
have traded anything i would have
trained the second half of my life to
achieve that goal you're locked in dude
who is protecting you guys from
yourselves the trainers
they're supposed to
the wives the girlfriends back in 2009 i
was getting ready for their mr olympia
on that thursday night i wasn't feeling
right next you know i'm puking my brains
out i lost 20 pounds within that time
period emts were called at 5 30 in the
morning
and um they did not want me to compete
and i probably shouldn't have
but
yeah was i praying a god saying like
please let me compete absolutely because
i'm thinking my purpose was like
these fans have flown so far that i just
need to show up i just want to show up i
just want to do it i just want to try
i'm not going to win but i want to try
and i made it and i had to make a deal
with the emts and say if i get sick one
more time while they're there i have to
quit
and i didn't but they still stayed for
like another hour
to check vitals and this and that um
you know i almost feel bad for even you
know and i'm not comparing myself but
it's going back to what you're saying i
mean my mindset was just like i gotta
keep going
so it is hard but
again
i wasn't by myself when i was sick
so you have to make sure if any advice
for the athletes you've got to make sure
guys that you that you're not by
yourself maybe maybe maybe maybe let me
ask you a different question maybe uh
is how often does the mr olympia brand
hold trainers accountable and have
conversations with them what's the
relationship between the brand and the
trainers if they're that heavily
involved in these types of decisions
good question in addition to that what
what's the qualifications to be an
olympia trainer how do you do these guys
are they olympia certified how do you i
mean it'd be no different than a boxing
trainer it's the same thing so i mean
like
it's the same thing like but i'm curious
the first one is there a relationship
between mr olympia and the trainers or
no okay i mean it's not like so it's
independent they can do whatever they
want to do right okay and ultimately i'm
just gonna call for what it is i mean
we're grown men
women whatever that compete
i have to be okay with what i do with my
own body as well but what gerard was
saying earlier who's protecting the
athlete from themselves
and usually it's supposed to be your
team
and i have always
made sure that i did have my best friend
there my girl there my trainer there
some some like when i say my best friend
like he would be the one that if
something were to happen he'd look me in
the eye and say i've known you for the
longest out of anybody i think you need
to stop and i would and he would be the
one that i would listen to so i think
athletes moving forward
you always got to make sure
that you have someone that
will
hit that button for you and you respect
it
um because you just don't want to push
yourself too far in anything
i mean pat you you you have a best
friend
that would probably sit you down and be
like hey man you know you're working too
much this and that you know or hey man i
i think you need to spend more time with
your family or whatever and you would
listen to them i think we all have those
people you had panic attacks anxiety
attacks plenty of them yeah
you know just
yeah this this is a different world yeah
because this is i didn't put stuff you
know i'm not yeah no it's a very
different world in you're dealing with
chemical and you're definitely i mean
i'm just going to call it for what it is
you're you're definitely dealing with
you know chemical muscle enhancement
you're definitely dealing with certain
things i'm not going to speculate on
what he was doing or anything like that
all i know is that my friend died man
yeah he passed and and you know um i'm
i don't i i just need more information i
need more data so listen i just wanted i
just i thought it was i appreciate you
know you sharing because i'm sure the
audience is is uh wondering what your
thoughts are and i saw where you were at
before i thought it was appropriate for
you to share your thoughts with it and
uh to the bodybuilding world man you
know it's a
it's one of those things that when a guy
decides to go compete in that world it's
tough to explain the hide the desire to
want to do that it's not for everybody
people think it's just a regular thing
it's so technical and detailed for what
they do um
prayers goes out to george and his
family on what they're going through
right now because at the end of the day
i wonder what they're thinking about
they're the ones that are probably going
through the toughest pains right now
seeing these stories coming from all
over the people so if if dylan ortiko
wanted to be a bodybuilder what would
you say
uh
like at what level
they want to be mr olympia i would say
only do it if you have a chance to win
the whole thing not to just compete
it's what i would say yeah only do it if
you have the chance i would have them
go sit with guys like him to say
you'd be a top 10 guy you ain't going to
be you ain't going to be so i don't
think you ought to do it and then at
that point if you want to do it you know
for yourself to have fun with that
you just said yeah i don't see a point
to do mr olympia unless if you're gonna
win the whole thing matter of fact i
don't even think there's point to
a lot of things until you can become
very very uh good at that world uh
everyone's got their own talent i think
there's uh certain people that like i
lived to this morning i was at the gym
early i loved right now what's going on
you right now training are you and i
gonna go compete senior mr olympia
anytime soon i don't know he may but he
was talking about the last time but but
the extreme nature of it doesn't doesn't
scare you i i think one of my kids is
going to pursue some kind of extreme
level of competition whether it's
business hollywood script sports you
know i don't know and there's nothing i
can tell them to stop because you
couldn't tell me anything to stop nobody
can tell me to stop you can't there you
just can't tell somebody like that what
they're going to be doing
you said was really actually what you
said is actually what i told myself
was like if if i'm gonna do this
i better make sure that i'm making a
living from it
and that i can get everything out of it
that i want
and if i'm doing the mr olympia best day
i'm sure better be able to be highly i
mean highly competitive
and if i'm not i gotta give myself like
three to five years and i gotta pick
another path i agree yeah i agree you
said something that i just gotta i have
that question like to me you said you
would have done whatever drugs or
whatever it took
and if you were to be dead by the age of
40 so be it die on your sword in the
ring for sure that to me is is
look respect to your opinion that to me
is the exact opposite of how i'm living
my life
i want to live a long time i want to
have kids i want to have grandkids
when you were younger um can't explain
it to you right i'm not judging you i'm
just letting you know where i'm at i i i
feel a little judgment though i feel
like you are judging me
i just i think you see all these
athletes
you know the saddest thing i go to the
[ __ ] dolphins game and you see these
guys
and they get paraded out on the field
and they're 75 years old now and their
legacy is that they were the undefeated
team on the dolphins
50 years later they're like i was on the
team it's like buddy
do something else with your life at this
point i'm not saying that none of them
aren't dude you want to see one of the
best things in the world watch watch the
86 mets documentary that that's great
and we talked about it a little bit uh
once upon a time in cleans watch lenny
dykstra in that in that dock and then
they ask him they're like was it worth
it he goes i was on the greatest team in
the history of sports what else is ever
going to compare to that okay i was
talking about it 35 years later the guy
is toothless and brainless at this point
but that's my point is that you're
willing to sacrifice everything for the
first 25 30 years of your life by the
way the rest of your life
by the way the world is ran by those
people that's what i was going to do
yeah yeah what do you mean let me let me
yeah
what country are you living in right now
the united states of america okay the
people who founded it what did they do
they fought for their freedom of course
you think there was some people in
britain and they're like
don't don't compare lenny dykstra to
george washington oh gerard no no
no no wait a minute no facts you said
dolphins i'm not talking gerard you said
dolphins okay it's a very i'm just
saying it's people that give everything
dude you know what you just said right
there what did i say
are you talking about adam do you like
adam i think let me explain to you what
so you mean to tell me so right now your
22 year old son is watching this
and he's obsessed about being the
greatest whatever whatever whatever
you're going to tell them dude relax if
it means if that means if it means
putting some harmful products in no body
i'm dying in there
dolphins have nothing to do with that i
didn't say putting yourself
i'm giving
using gerard's words if it means ruining
your body and literally gerard's a
little extreme in the way that that's
that's what i was saying no but you said
dolphins that's the type of compulsion
if you eliminate dolphins
i'm saying is it
for me is do you want to
die by 40
or
live a long life at 30 something 35 i
understand what you're saying you have
to ask
yeah but you have to ask yourself about
it
i think that 35 would you still have
done that but it's like 35 dude legacy
means so much okay so legacy c35 in a
weird way i'll tell you in a weird way
my body would have died but my legacy
would have lived on i would have been a
big leaguer forever
you understand do you understand what
i'm saying like all my every doesn't do
anything for you nothing
what if you're a big leaguer but you
were on the bench the entire time you're
in the big leagues bro like i i don't
guys i don't i know it's dumb
i i don't know how to explain it to you
it's so funny i don't know how to
explain there's there's something
there's some minor leaguer out there
listening to this that knows exactly
what i'm saying okay of course
let me give you a little optics
you said if you were on the bench at
least you would have died on the bench
there's a big d and i want you to live
to the literally you're 150 years old
he's
gonna go down a seven time mister that's
a legacy yeah you because you made it to
the major leagues and you you know you
hit 220 for half a season that's
something that he doesn't do okay i get
it but if
but to use pat's point if you're going
to do this i want you to be the best of
the best the best not riding the pine no
man like that's what he said if dylan if
dylan ortik are going to do it he wants
him to be the old man champion the old
man and the sea yeah you ever read that
you're gonna throw some ernest hemingway
earnest what have you ever read it the
old man yes in eighth grade i had to
read it
he was willing to die for that fish he
was [ __ ] willing to die for a fish
for that fish yeah i read moby dick for
that fish all right hey let me ask you a
question step outside with you right now
gerard hey you like die for that fish
you like art right you like art pat
right he's the archive okay so basquiat
how old did he die 27 right 27.
talk about impact that a heroin overdose
so obviously he was doing it like you
know creating these masterpieces right
you know how expensive those pieces are
right now
we
very very expensive right pat a basket
that's it's it's ridiculous yeah all
right let me give you let me let me
throw something in your way
would you rather would you rather be by
the way would you rather be
tupac
died by at age 25 or whatever would you
rather 25 is tupac dead and i'm not
joking about that like
i'm not saying that he's not like like
he's not we've covered one story yeah
he's just going to put this
would you rather be tupac or biggie they
both died you know in their 20s yeah or
would you rather be jay-z worth a
billion and he's going to live for until
he's 100 years old well who would you
rather be you don't have a choice though
you don't have to no you do not have a
choice i want to be jay-z you know what
i'm trying to tell you is
i love girls girls yeah so so the point
i'm trying to make to is everyone's
dreams are different buddy get it but if
you're just so you end up dead you right
now i guarantee you there's a group of
people listening to this that fully
subscribe to your way of thinking
fully
yeah and yeah this is a safe life i
fully get it and i guarantee there's a
group by the way like your opinion man
but the point is there's certain people
man who feel they got a calling on them
who feel like they want to do something
bigger and that life is not necessarily
the most exciting life to get to the
point of it becoming a reality that
journey can be annoying at times i i
feel you i get it but it's also i i i'll
use this analogy that i use with uh when
i do sauce talks you've got one minute
you're changing the story go fine put a
timer i see kids in their 20s that are
partying like there's no tomorrow in
south speech they're spending all their
money they're yoloing it up they're
killing it they're doing
and and i have to remind them dude one
day you're going to be 30. one day
you're going to be 40. dude that's don't
spend all your money
don't do all the drugs now
don't do all the drugs now do it later
do it spread it out save your money
occasionally all right next have some
moderation dude like i'm done doing all
the drums
you guys did you guys go to the bar
before this with adam like is has adam
had a few drinks today
i want to live a long life i want to
have kids i want to be a grandpa i want
to do this let's talk about a serious
topic playboy releases october covering
featuring a man go ahead let me say that
one more time
october's uh uh issue of playbook
playboy
is a
man uh 201 digital government future
bretman rock a 23 year old male social
media influencer originally from the
philippines as bret mann the company
said on twitter when they unveiled the
october cover friday attached to the
post was a short video bret man dressed
in a woman's lingerie in heels with a
bow tie and bunny ears completing the
look rock
rose to fame as an influencer on youtube
and vine later releasing his own line of
makeup to go along with the makeup
tutorial videos he often posts rocks
appearance on the playboy cover will not
be the first time he has appeared on a
magazine cover having previously been
seen on the cover of gay times in 2019.
so why playboy over playgirl i want to
get your insight i think you have the
best insight have you have you ever seen
him do his social media
i've seen him on different videos he is
legit hilarious so before i get into
like why i think this is definitely very
wrong and not
cool at all man
uh he's hilarious and my ex-girlfriend
used to love him and watched uh his
stuff
but this is where playboy's at now this
is how tarnished their brand is this is
how irrelevant they are that they're
looking for something
to get them out of the dumpster fire
that playboy is now
they had i don't know we've talked about
on the podcast what you could buy
playboy brand for and turn it around and
turn into something freaking awesome
but this is where they're going now
they're taking the gay dude putting them
in heels and throwing him on the cover
not play girl
play boy
hugh would be turning in his grave right
now and on someone who has partied in
the playboy mansion a few times
there's a lot
better stuff out there to pick from than
the bret man
i'm just letting you know i wonder what
the girls think
seriously because it is a competition
right as a model yeah you know they took
they took their job
you're supposed to be a feminist
supporting women
empowerment jobs
my first reaction is why not play girl
now you know what you you said that
first yeah i i asked the question well
you brought that up yesterday when he
said why not play girl over playboy but
then also
um
is it selling
you know is there numbers that support
you know what i mean like is it a
magazine would we be talking about it
would we be talking about it look it's
true no it works i couldn't care less
man is this still more than anything
else is this still shocking to us
like is it i'll be honest when i saw
miss mrs nevada i was shocked i was like
that's that that's
and then i thought like wow you know
that i felt bad for biological women
because i'm like man
this is a this is a a
a miracle of surgery right what's his
nevada what was that mrs nevada is a
transgender woman now who won mrs nevada
and you know very beautiful and all that
but i mean like that was shocking in
who it was right
uh
whereas this this playboy thing to me is
just it's it's a police understand it's
a gimmick yeah that is that's that's yep
it's missing nevada so
yeah that that to me like vegas baby
yeah if that was on now if that was on
the if if she was on the cover of
playboy would that even raise an eyebrow
would we talk about it you know like i'm
i'm sorry is it a good thing that i'm so
desensitized but is that what they're
saying nothing burger but i guess we're
in society i mean we're just like okay
so whatever is just gonna be clickbait
and uh
something that we can just talk about it
doesn't matter what it is then huh i got
stats here here's a playboy magazine i'm
purely looking at business
demos this is the playboy magazines
demographics if you can flip it so the
audience can see david
so male 83 percent female 17.3 okay fine
age 18 to 24 a quarter
25 to 34 another quarter 35 to 44 21
45 to 54 15 and a half percent so say 18
to 54 is majority of their market
point seven percent above 55 watch
playboy okay
look at playboy household income sixteen
percent make six figures that's pretty
solid by the way people with money
subscribe to playboy
marital status forty percent are married
45 are single and you got the rest
full-time professional management
student that's subscribing to the
content so now
if this is a publicity stunt for for
getting people to talk about it am i
gonna go buy it
if i'm getting publicity on this i'm
probably not gonna buy it do you
understand what i'm saying i don't know
if this kind of publicity gets me to buy
it
if it's to attract a new audience okay
cool yes you're doing it if you are
trying to attract a new audience but
that new audience isn't as big of an
audience as people think it's less than
one percent that you're looking at it as
an audience so if you
jerry springer years ago had was doing
his jre jre jerry and one day says i'm
smarter than this i know politics i used
to be mayor of cincinnati before i cut
that check to that lady but i'm a mayor
i know politics i should have my own
show and he started talking about
serious issues in his morning show his
numbers plummeted you know what they
realized who are your viewers yeah is is
mothers and wives that are staying home
that just want to be entertained for the
time that you got what are you doing
talking about serious issues that's the
last thing they want to hear you talk
about and you lost your audience so
we're going to find that if in the next
six twelve eighteen months if playboy
banker files through another bankruptcy
again they totally disrespected their
audience but if this thing takes off
listen maybe they were targeting an
audience that we were not it does it
reeks of desperation it does reek of
desperation for sure i agree with you
yeah
this seems like it's a publicity stunt
but nobody like by the way when you were
reading the stats they're just like
everyday american
you know 30 year old guy makes 60 grand
a year
you know maybe he's married maybe he's
not just
wants to see a hot chick see some
titties yeah all good have a have a beer
see some titties
all good
now i gotta see this
seven o'clock adam is by far and away my
favorite house
whatever you did all right let's do one
last time
let's go about let's do pandora papers
because we haven't done it yet go to
page three to do pandora papers this is
the last story before we wrap up i gotta
head out uh pandora papers biggest ever
leak of offshore data exposes financial
secrets of rich and powerful this is a
guardian story kai if you can pull it up
as well millions of documents reveal
offshore deals assets of more than 100
billionaires 30 world leaders 300 public
officials branded the pandora papers the
cash included 11.9 million files from
companies hired by wealthy clients to
create offshore structure and trust in
tax havens such as panama dubai monaco
switzerland cayman islands the pandora
papers represent the latest and the
largest in terms of data volume in the
series of major leaks of financial data
that have con convulsed the offshore
world since 2013 the famous ones on the
uh that appear in pandora's papers
shakira ringo starr tony blair king
abdullah ii of jordan guillermo lasso
president of ecuador elton john claudia
scheifer and
schiffer and amongst many other names
who else do you have here tony blair
yeah we've talked about those guys
vladimir putin's also on there the
papers revealed the extraordinary hidden
wealth of russian president vladimir
putin's inner circle his childhood
friend and an alleged former lover are
amongst those revealed to have amassed
extraordinary wealth hidden through
offshore companies okay uh what do you
think about this gerard
this uh
this just goes to show guys that there
is a completely
different world out there when we talk
about the global elites and people are
like oh it's a conspiracy you're going
crazy again how many more times do you
need to see it how many times do you
need to see the the the panama papers
how many times you need to see the
pandora papers how many times do you
need to have who
how many more jeffrey epstein's do you
need to have be paraded in front of you
you know how many more times do you have
to read about the pa the uh the pentagon
papers guys
there is a completely different world
out there for the global elites that we
know nothing about that while they're
taxing you and taking all of your stuff
all right and taking your future and
right now they're gonna raise the debt
limit where okay what what where does
that money go that money goes how does
trump pull us out of the paris accords
how does he pull us out of the who okay
so our money goes to nato american tax
dollars goes to nato goes to the paris
accords the
the climate change this climate change
climate change this and that and then it
all ends up
where
in these offshore accounts with these
globalist oligarchs it's a big club as
the late great george carlin would say
and you ain't in it and the person here
that i feel most disgusted about is
julian assange julian assange is going
to die in a prison
he's going to die in a prison for
exposing the truth julian assange the
founder of wikileaks is going gonna die
and they're probably the elites will
probably have his name stricken from the
records and there'll be a few crazy q
anon conspiracy theorists on a
blockchain 100 years from now talking
about there was a guy named julian
assange who knew that all this stuff was
going on knew that there was sex
trafficking going on knew that there was
offshore accounts where people were
using diamonds to to you know sell
access and they were funneling billions
and billions and billions of
hard-working everyday people's money
into their own freaking pockets while
they're dividing us down
uh you know what i can go for another
hour and a half don't don't get me
started on this guys if
if you're not reading this if you're not
paying attention to this and if you
don't see what's actually going on i
will we can't help you anymore but why
is this any any of this new
like this has been going on for years we
all saw on the wolf of wall street swiss
bank accounts jordan belford strapping
money onto people you brought up the
panama papers
wealthy people shocker alert don't want
to give up all their loot to the
government it's not it is what it is
it's not the money right the money the
money is is the hypocrisy where they'll
sit there and they'll tell you that
you're not paying your fair share and i
need to take another 25 of mr bet
david's wealth because i need blah blah
blah there's poor kids and you know
starving in sarasota and then the money
ends up where okay we we don't have a
revenue problem in this country and they
want to do a global tax now mind you
they're they're they're the global taxes
coming global business taxes coming
global income taxes coming it's all
coming right so we
whatever amount of revenue we generate
they don't pay their taxes it goes to
their offshore they don't play the the
rules that they make us play by they
don't play by those rules so the
hypocrisy pisses people off and i can
understand because the average person
that doesn't have 50 million dollars
more than that figure out half the
person doesn't have 50 000. you have to
understand the access that's being sold
this is this is an access game this is
okay tony blair tony blair the prime
minister of of uh
great britain our biggest ally in the
world the head of nato right the front
lines on europe
now you make 250 000 pounds a year buddy
where did you get 100 million dollars
how
where'd you get that money bud
you you make 200 grand where'd you get
the money
you you got caught with 50 million where
where'd you get that money buddy what
deals are being made that we don't know
what access is being sold that we don't
know
you understand what i'm saying they want
to go after they want to go after
trump's uh uh tax reports how many how
long do we hear about trump's tax
reports we need trump's tax returns we
need trump's tax returns he's lying
about his money he's actually a deca
millionaire he's not a billionaire and
then these guys have have the balls to
have a hundred million dollars stored
offshore where'd they get the money dude
where how did they acquire this wealth
well you're oh i mean tony blair good
question but obviously everyone else on
this list elton john
uh
vladimir putin yeah exactly we know
where they got the freaking money i mean
they got the but something that you're i
don't know honestly discounting there is
an entire profession in this country
called estate planners trusts and
estates attorneys tax attorneys i go to
a conference called the heckerling
estate planning conference i'll be going
in january there's an entire
occupation
that the elite
mega billionaire multi-millionaires hire
these tax estate to avoid estate taxes
it's all legal it's all legal where's
the revenue coming from what what do you
mean the revenue so
i'm saying what you're saying these
people have these money and they're
they're legally avoiding estate taxes
yeah but he's saying like where is 250
uh generating how many millions of money
but i can assure that we know where
elton john got his money and tony okay
king abdullah got his money right of
cyprus ringo starr got his money some of
these people actually made this money
they just want to avoid taxes which i'm
okay with that's just theft baby i
really don't
so which one is more concerned with
where they got the money i'm more
concerned with where are they
the head of the state where they got the
money sure
does this hurt them these guys right now
who are on that list sitting there
pissed off that these things are public
do you think they're frustrated about it
look yeah okay what's the bad look on it
what's the bad look the fact that they
have offshore money money offshore i
don't know what's the change is anything
we know that rich people do stuff to
avoid taxes okay
you know how they got the money good
question but that's that's something
pelosi we saw what happened with pelosi
that there's two business models one go
make it yourself two go create the laws
to benefit you i mean that's the
politician
yeah i mean it's it's not anything new
that's going on i just wondered this
this i mean this keeps happening over
and over and over again people are
fascinated with knowing how much money
people have you know oh my god let me
see how much money this guy is let me
see where he has his money at but do you
think these guys were getting these
papers hoping other people's names were
on there and they were disappointed is
it kind of like i was hoping we should
have trump or we were opening someone oh
okay let's just put it out there anyways
and write it up are you saying the
guardian or whoever whoever got this
were they were some of these guys so
excited to have other names on their
shakira okay good for shakira you know
what this tells me with shakira whoever
accountant is and whoever her cpas she's
probably got better ones than j.lo does
so you know
who's shakira's people working for her
that's advising on things like this but
no i i i think maybe they were looking
for other names too that was going to be
a little bit bigger and it didn't hit
and quite frankly those people are
disappointed all the other guys every
few years you're going to find out where
the wealth especially nowadays people
are getting better at getting this kind
of information this is no longer the
biggest bigger news was like you talked
about earlier was jen sackey refusing to
admit well let's read that let's let's
wrap that up page eight sake won't say
whether hunter biden has divested from
chinese private equity firm or not
uh
did i say page idea white house press
secretary jane sachin monday refused to
say whether president biden's son hunter
has divested his 10 stake in the chinese
equity from the firm despite the
president's pledge to prohibit family
members from engaging in international
business dealings chinese business
records reviewed by fox news indicate
hunter biden still holds 10 stake in one
chinese private equity firm this comes
after the decade then candidate joe
biden said in october 2019 that his
family would not
engage in business dealings with other
countries overseas hunters previously
sat on the chinese firm's board before
announcing in october 2019 that he would
be stepping down from mounting scrutiny
from his father's presidential bid i
actually want to know how sacky answered
this question can you pull up
exactly what she said in here if you
have it
uh i want to know what that exchange
sounded like was it like blowing you off
or was it actually an answer
that's not saying
about uh
hunter biden let me see how this was
uh
don't imagine what china has on hunter
biden can you imagine the blackmail that
they have on joe biden hunter biden like
this dude is like a la he's fredo right
like i mean he's fredo corleone he's not
saying the exact same thing that they
that they the liberals said about
trump and russia i would say bush's
daughters would be closer to hunter
biden but that's even like that's really
disrespecting his daughter this is this
guy's a he's a massive drug addict this
is her answer her answer is i'd point
you to his representative on that he
doesn't work in the administration
and then uh again i convey to you and
then i think i'm going to have to move
on that you should talk to his
representatives saki said in february
that hunter was in the process of
unloading his shares in february he has
been working to unwind his investment
but i would certainly point you
uh uh he is a private citizen i would
point you to him or his lawyers on the
outside on any update so she said in
october and february that this was going
to happen now she's just avoiding you
saying it's not my job she's not part of
the administration
go look elsewhere
you know
as a voter do you think that you know
gets get somebody that voted a voter for
them to say yeah i really don't care
like does that change your mind about
biden's vote in 2024 are you kind of
like oh my gosh i can't believe this has
happened it's going to change my way of
voting i've been pretty clear i could
care less about hunter briden i i'm glad
that he's not
like if he was involved in the
administration
alarm bells would be going off but he's
a private citizen he's a drug addict i'm
sure he's done some shady stuff but
thank god he's not in the room with
biden making any decisions that's not
that's not true though did the
bobalinsky stuff back in the one back
when the election was was rounding in
the form did that bother you at all
that turned out not to be true that that
that story would like was bobolinsky was
the guy who came on the the
turned out it was 100 it was very
verified by multiple sources i don't
know literally it does does nothing for
the emails the big guy gets 10 with i do
say that kai does take 10 that's
something that he jokes about a lot you
know what i just i don't think that the
hunt i think my sisters couldn't care
less either no matter how many times i
tried explaining to them like what a
national security threat this was what a
liability this was to the national
security united states they they could
not care advice to the right-wing media
pushing the hunter media hunter biden
stuff down the throat people that they
just don't care
like if they they just don't like you
can argue why you should
it's it's almost like i didn't care when
eric does if she feels like a low blow
does it feel like a low blow
a house like going after a guy's family
a guy you know
i think it's fair game but if you're
doing that with like why would you vote
for this man hunter bite and smoke crack
it's like okay but it's the it's the
does nothing for me the blackmail but
the same thing when they when they would
make fun of eric trump all the time i
was like baron
i don't care like
listen everyone has family bill
clinton's brother was a weirdo obama's
brother can like i tend to agree with
you like like
like people are going to have people in
their family and i didn't like her what
was the the woman from alaska i didn't
like her at all sarah palin her daughter
and daughter the daughter had a
handicapped kid that was horrible leave
the family out but this is different i i
if this is different specifically
because okay he was illegally selling
access and i'm totally cool with the
press finding out what the hell is going
on i'm not saying leave him alone
but unless it's actually something
shocking and
like reveals something that actually
compromises joe biden in fact then all
right i don't think most people care
does the hunter buy stuff bother you at
all or no
i'm so confused right now uh so so this
guy
is doing business with the number one
enemy that doesn't do nothing to you and
it's the son of the president yeah i
don't know about that bro so so you
forget that a guy is doing business with
the number one enemy i'm not so cool
with the china thing who
would that should be enough that's
that's that's uh that's the issue
so you're the your father is the
president of the united states
and your son is doing business with
china and there's dealing with anything
with china i'm not cool with yeah i'll
say that all i'm saying to you is if
you're linked
they're making them out to be some sort
of like global henchman businessman he's
like some crackhead dude but but she's
trying to make money listen and i get
that you can be compromised let me let
me get it it's not like let me give a
different perspective how regulated is
the securities industry very right okay
so let's just say i'm doing a business
deal and i
funnel the money through
uh a non-licensed securities person
who's really bringing the business in
and it's wink wink don't worry about it
but you're doing business that's that
all the time so that's what's going on
here except they dictate china's
dictating a lot of the deals okay so
they can pay this guy should be held
accountable who should be held
accountable if if he's doing something
illegal then
bring some charges against him but it's
linked to his father and his father's
your president forget forget about i'm
not even concerned about joe biden if if
hunter biden is doing something illegal
bring some charges again no you're not
hearing like money doesn't funnel like
that money's funneling through
a guy's here hey i need a favor from
this guy can you do this and i give you
the money and you make the phone call
and that guy you know there's so let me
let me throw something before cause
obviously i know you you tend to agree
with donald trump on things when
everything was coming out that
uh donald trump jr was taking these
meetings and made these phone calls it
was fake and russia
and uh it was fake it was verified
russell brand a guy on the far left who
came out and talked about elections we
care less what russell branson has
because it doesn't favor your argument
what was fake exactly no he actually the
whole
but there were meetings with russia when
trump went out there like you're saying
that what meetings would russia you're
saying that was what meetings would
russia mean that russia had zero help uh
with uh with anything oh wait wait wait
are you saying that trump had russia
help him on the election i'm not saying
that i'm saying but russia did too those
are two different things bro no no no no
no you can't say something so when the
stories were out and here's my question
no stories were out
u.s is involved in all the elections
they tamper every country that's
powerful tampers and other but there's a
difference to say help me out okay
versus a person individually
independently does it that's not the
same thing my question to you is when
news was because this is news to me news
here one day out the other when news was
out there about
donald trump jr eric trump or divesting
of other companies they're compromised
at that point four years ago we were
like well you know they should look into
it they should oh no no let me tell you
what let me tell you what i was thinking
about it what my mind went to this if
this is true
it's game over for his entire family's
legacy
if any of that is stuff is true trump is
using america to make money okay if any
of that is true you're using america to
make money and that's where i'm at well
but it is
i don't know if it's true
what i'm saying is bring some charges do
you remember the new york post story
that was supposed to be posted that
everything was shut down and five days
later they're like you can put it up and
that one new york post story that was
going viral was blocked all over twitter
why right before the election why what
happened
of course not seriously
we talked about it on the podcast
you know what i like about you let me
tell you what i like about you know the
movie you know the movie what's the
goldfish movie what is that one the dory
dory's the one that's got the memory
yeah
one of the best qualities of shooters is
amnesia you got it
the point is you got a good memory let
me know what's on the laptop let me just
let me just say one thing
you know how many times i wake up and
think even think about hunter biden zero
why not and most people don't because
there's so many other things that's
going on in life that i got to think
about hunter biden why not if he's doing
some illegal [ __ ]
bring some charges against them would
you have this but you want me to like
run down every rabbit hole because you
mentioned hunter piden's name
it's annoying okay what about the laptop
what are your thoughts on tell me what's
on the laptop i don't know about the
laptop show me some things on the laptop
what do you do on the laptop all i've
heard for the last year is hunter bite
and hunter bite and arthur binding what
do you
what do you do
bring some charges they're trying to
they're trying to get the media to cover
the laptop they're trying to get the
media to cover these stories so that you
could be aware of it i hate this it's
because they're trying to get the media
as if the right doesn't have media news
max isn't out there one fox missus
doesn't we just covered the first story
that fox news gets more viewers than
anyone else yeah the media the media fox
news is the media yeah and that's
exactly right so it comes up tell your
friends at fox news to start covering
the story so
2.5 million people a night know exactly
what we're talking about it's the other
three million that are living in an
opposite reality that we're trying to
convince that these things that are
facts are facts right so just because
hannity says that it's not a fact but
i'm not a i'm not a hannity guy yeah you
are i'm not a handicapper i'm going to
paint you as well hey
have you ever did you ever read a robert
spaulding's book stealth war
did you ever read that uh no
there's a few there's a few parts in
there that i think you would be very
interested in
pertaining to the relationship that
hunter biden actually has okay um i i
definitely think fyi it's not just the
left it's both of them mcconnell's also
on the right all the connections to
china so his wife is chinese this is
more the issue
but my point is this yeah even when we
talked about what's her name elizabeth
wu yeah is that her name i just make
that up elizabeth what's up what's
mcconnell's wife's name
even when they've told stories about her
it doesn't nothing for me and i'm not a
mcconnell fan but i'm not going to go
down the rabbit hole of like well yep
mcconnell's compromised
there it is yeah but the figurehead of
the gop for the last 30 years compromise
that concerns me
it should concern you yeah but unless
they've proven that he's done something
illegal it's just a story in the news
did the general military stuff bother
you at all or no
let me ask you a question when's the
last time when's the last time serious
question though when's the last time you
said like remember the scene where
uh the day uh giuliani took down like
245 of them you know mobsters got
arrested or joe piston and you saw all
of them handcuffed walking out when's
the last time you saw that happening to
congressmen and senators
is
do you know why it's never happened do
you think it's because they've never
broken the law
because they created them
can you imagine that scene how come
that's never happened but have you seen
have you seen pastors or priests going
through handcuffs and going to jail yeah
have you seen mobsters have you seen
athletes have you seen business people
have you seen the only industry that
apparently we've never seen that before
is politicians well how does that make
any sense some yeah so they're they're
the angels they're the angels they're
not all that's what they're not at all
yeah
on the left or the right
of course
this is not a politician once did we say
left or right this is politician
who's not a politician his father is i
get it he finally deals through his son
he's the bad guy he funnels deals
through his son
sammy the good boy gurana told me he
says john's never killed anybody alexis
says i don't care if john's ever killed
anybody
he said it's not the person that kills
them it's the person that orders other
people to kill them that he says sammy
says i've
he says he's got four that he took out
or whatever the numbers that he's got
out of his 19 he says the rest i ordered
somebody else to do the hit right so
it's not him doing it so it's not not
necessarily biting doing the work but
he's got somebody else shadier has done
shadier things more things that are
illegal trump or biden not even close
you think it's biden do you know why
tell me why because if you do it in
business you eventually get caught and
go to jail
that's why
but in politics you know did you not
hear me three minutes ago
in business you eventually get caught
you can't fight it
you eventually get caught in business
you you can skirt the laws for sure
no no skirt the laws is fine i don't
disagree with skirt you can play in the
great yeah but well he said that he did
but politicians can play in the black
white gray blue green purple whatever
the hell they want to do because they
create the laws that's why we need a
clean house anyone over 70 needs to be
out of politics this isn't about seven
it doesn't take seven years to learn bad
habits it doesn't take seven years to
learn bad habits clean house you just
need to go to the right environment we
go to jail what happens when people go
to jail what do people call jail
training ground to produce more
criminals in other words okay you go to
politics you're like i'm going to be a
statesman i love america
i'm going to do such great things
hey do you know if we give you 200
dollars right there i'm gonna get two
hundred thousand dollars sketchy of
course just to everybody does it okay
and then johnny cash movie just take it
everybody does it you know walk the line
yeah that's the training ground for
producing people that know how to abuse
have you ever interviewed a lobbyist
have you ever had like somebody who was
an actor i have a very close friend of
mine
that's a
i can't say his name that's a very
powerful lobbyist
for a long time that he left the
business
and he's he tells me stuff okay i will
never re he tells me stuff and he says
pat as dirty as you think as it is
he says it's a million times dirty he
says you don't even know how dirty it is
and how to negotiate with each other he
says you don't even know how they
negotiate with us like what things we
get you don't even know if the lobbyists
left the game and they could not exist
it'd be a very different world today the
people that would win office would be
very different people if you didn't have
lobbyists and if you couldn't take
campaign there's a lot of different
things you can change up what's a
difference
we have to explain one day what the
actual way our government works now with
lobbyists and if anybody out there wants
to know like what a lobbyist is and it
really and explain kind of my time in
government watch thank you for smoking
i'll give a plug for a phenomenal movie
watch thank you for stopping phenomenal
yeah
it's uh you know it's it it's amazing
how accurate that was
yeah and they they hang out in the state
house i can only imagine what it's like
uh at a federal level but they hang out
in the state house from the chamber to
your office is fair game so these guys
you try to run from the chamber so you
know the session will break and all the
elected officials they'll leave the
chamber and then the lobbyists like
cockroaches they they swarm and they try
to get their mark before they get to
their office so that that walk down the
hall is like insane and that's where all
the action it's all illegal it's all
legal
all right having said that it's 737
something like we should get cameras and
like microphones in those halls yeah
right just it's a fair game it's very
good you've been a lobbyist sit down
with pat on a pbd interview like we just
did like like you just did with the guy
from facebook we need to get like like
an insider series going here we get
another feedback have you been getting
from that facebook interview dude people
are messaging me texting me telling me
stuff that that a heart many people said
they couldn't finish the entire
interview yeah it's the most common
comment i'm getting i couldn't watch the
whole thing it was that disturbing i
don't know what's his name again
sean spiegel okay go watch that
interview y'all sean spiegel anyways
we're not here this week obviously
that's why we did it today uh next
tuesday i'll be back next tuesday
caroline or no every tuesday and
thursday next week both days
both days next week even though it's the
birthday weekend next week's not the
next week okay all right sounds good so
we'll do it again next tuesday same time
take care everybody have a wonderful
weekend if you're going to the mr
olympia this saturday phil may be doing
a live podcast on valuetainment to hear
his feedback of the mr olympia i'm sure
you're going to want to tune in if
you're in that world take care bye